hey I'm Allah villains go hi I'm prison
story
I'm Naomi Scott and this is their wildly
into you the internet doesn't you know
more than we do
is Kristen Stewart this is very scary
whoever Google do this informs this
answer just saying I highlighted the
tricks too squeaky-clean search history
I have to say just do it in the world
are related to curiosity is Christmas
syrup left-handed shockingly down the
line on that one right-handed it's
almost like they wanted you to be left I
know but I wish I was a part of the
left-handed Club I'm a part of it like a
few pretty cool like more you know
marginal clubs but not the well don't
use the lefty scissors in school is
Kristen Stewart and natural don't know I
kind of have like no hair color it's
actually right now is my right see the
tips are blonde unnaturally and then
right now this is like my natural hair I
think Mouse definitely mouths and drown
it's like the word mousy yeah it's like
a non-color
but yeah right la salon is Christmas do
it on social media uh I mean I have like
a private one for you guys yeah just I'm
gonna be in the Galant play with you
guys I can't like be completely left on
your game she's very much but I don't
gray show media yeah you guys are
missing out yeah sorry y'all
it's just for my exclusive friends
alright I love this oh maybe go Oh guys
look what's weird how your house how to
pronounce I mean
[Music]
I mean how do you can't you read
actually now that I've said that there
is a bit of a discrepancy because if
it's not I mean yeah so weird thing my
mum who named me of course
Naomi's got with an a cool used to call
me like nice like no I like what there's
the eyes at the end it's Naomi Naomi how
tall Naomi scuffin yeah how tall name is
got teeny tiny little I am a hundred and
sixty three centimeter let's be exact on
knowledge why are you little subsidies
today I should be something that people
say to me they're like oh you you look
sure it rose I did you get that off all
the time yeah um how did Naomi Scott and
Jordan sometimes meet that's really cute
oh so you're gonna tell us that said
okay I know I'm like did anyone actually
Google their hours letters um we met
when I was a baby when I was 16 years
old he young love there we go
JJ wants up next question oh oh was it
like at the movie theater no it was
actually at church oh well thank you
yeah we met Church good place to meet
you hubby guys yeah guys Church how did
Naomi Scott become famous because she's
an incredibly talented individual how
did Naomi Scott become famous I feel her
person asking that is like
[Laughter]
like literally how did she become famous
and thing is I'm not famous because
famous would mean that you'd have to
like you'd like you're famous oh just
wait and also you just sit alone and do
you don't get like people going hey
what's up dude yeah a little bit but I
get on the tube all the time
I think I'm this you're like you know I
know tennis wife does I mean you you
know you're pretty sweet or Beyonce
everyone she's very famous and she's
very modest and it's very cute yeah who
is okay and the reason there is is
actually soon as they see her they're
like but who are you really here am i
I'm uh I'm in Charlie's Angels on my
page and hey she's so much more than
that
and you wish you knew you wishing it
stay tuned to find out here we go
how oh there we go of course how tall is
that a blintz guess so my natural high
is 511 but I love rain boots with thick
heels especially the ones that I'm
wearing how strides say like when you
meet me I probably seem like 6:1 yes you
do a new hair kill it
yeah ok how old is Ella Billings go 1996
oh wow III I thought you were gonna say
million team my first memory was being 3
Wow ok seriously yeah what do you
remember I ran into my parents room and
I said I'm 3 but I went like this that's
freaky so you won't even I just can't
believe I just feel so close to you and
that's so weird
not many a lot older than you yeah well
abilities go from Wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
maybe I'm from London but my background
is British polish and Caribbean that's
why this makes a lot good
also like I mean it's a funny one
because people are like you're polish
and I'm like yeah now my surnames
belinskiy I'm like I'm not making it up
I promise you know what's funny is that
you know when it was how know me
Scott pronounced or whatever that was
like the amount the amount of people
that will go like Belinsky and I'm like
dude it's Belinsky like they just think
like European and so they're like Berlin
vilensky yeah there you go
what it was Kristen Stewart's first
movie oh I know
it's the safety of objects okay what
does Kristen Stewart's like how do you
say so many things good fire what rip
off that bit knee okay what color are
Kristen Stewart's eyes I know this you
guys if you really love me I swear to
God and look what color your eyes
beautiful green gray greeny right what
does Kristen's do it eat everything
everything and any well I mean honest it
you know we shouldn't eat as much meat
guy nothing I'm saying but lying like a
lot heart yeah crying earnestly what's
Naomi Scott what his name he's got doing
now doing this what is Naomi Scott's
middle name what's her middle like who
knows where was that good her middle
name is gg gg
it's a G grace do you know what I mean G
now social net
oh that you hate it no I actually hate
this okay yeah I know one no sorry no
one is hurting me oh I know you guys
okay I know you love me okay my favorite
color it's a difficult one because you
know what I don't even have a favorite
but let's be honest okay I love good and
every I used to hate pink but now I love
pink a lot thing could you right now
next up look we both interpreted
yesterday what country is Naomi Scott
from I mean Anglin I
what does Naomi Scott look like okay you
guys have to describe it what countries
know me Scott from there like why is she
a little bit cuz she's from England this
one it's very neat like you olinska
ninja absolutely absolutely
zodiac Libra Thank You Ella Berlinski
traca traca feel cornell's through
javelin 14 London how course you did
through javelin a-team London that like
makes so much sense right okay here we
go
Ella bilinski that was my first row
lightly grease Briggs in Midsomer
Murders me some of them know what we're
doing which is ridiculous but there's a
little bit of context is like a very
English show that's like introspect like
Molony he old people yeah yeah it's like
an outlaw you know kind of like mini
movies yes great and I was a suspect for
a really long time and you have to watch
the episode to find out if I did it or
not she knows how to really work the
system
the short film also about a murder II
situation I did yeah I thought that's
maybe what it was she's also a very
prolific person in every way she's like
in school still
she made short films like we watched ask
me she's being bright
my degree what did we learn guys I think
we knew we are we knew pretty much most
of that right I think we learned that
grammar is yeah grammar isn't
interesting at Google yes and I think if
you want to get the best answers write
something really like not grammatically
correct to find out what the answer is
you know your self more than the
internet does you know that's all that's
what I've learned it's a good good good
hmm